what's the guitar that that you have
that's the first one that you get in the
fire I have two old Martins but talk
about your little Coco guitar we were on
tour in 2019 in the summer it was like
June 2019 and Billy's album had come out
and it was doing great it was like the
first time
um I went to a guitar store with any
funds ever in my life I was like this is
crazy I could kind of get whatever I
want and I remember going in and I was
playing I was at the Guitar Center in
Boston right by Berkeley College of
Music so every inch of the store was was
19 year old kids going like shredding
yeah and I was so kind of uh pea shy in
the Guitar Center I'm not gonna sit down
and play a g I like I don't so
embarrassing right and so I just
eyeballed it and there was a toy guitar
there was a tiny Disney uh Cordoba Coco
guitar of that like uh wonderful movie
yeah that for 70 or something and it was
nylon string and I was like well it's
small enough that I'll sit in the lounge
on the bus and I can have it in my arms
and have people next to me not like be
taken up too much room yeah and I bought
it and like I remember the clerk being
like ringing me up and I was like do you
guys uh sell the case for this
no idiot
how about insurance you're just supposed
to break it but then but then we like
immediately wrote happier than ever and
then recorded exactly with that guitar
and so till then oh that's the guitar
well I was gonna say that that since
then uh to my uh
what would you call it I don't know to
my uh annoyance oh everyone thinks it's
a ukulele everyone thinks it's a ukulele
it's a baby it's a little sweet tiny
guitar is it is it a six string then
yeah it's regular ass guitar it's just
it does sound teeny like so we we do a
lot of things where they're like the
ukulele unhappier than ever it's amazing
and it really bothers me I really love
that thank you but it's a really easy
it's a kids guitarist was so easy to
play to your point about guitars after
you played it's it's the easiest I
remember you picked it up a couple weeks
ago and you were like this is so easy
yeah I mean it's made for a kid
literally it's like what you would get
for a kid if they wanted to learn my
favorite guitar move of all time is
there's this famous shot of the Ramones
on their way to a gig in like 76 and
they don't have guitar cases they have
their guitars in shitty shopping bags in
shopping bags like just like paper
shopping bags and it's just like no I'm
whoa we got our jeans on we got our
leather jacket so cool going downtown
we're gonna play some rock and
roll you know who knows where the case
is let's see just use these you know
Ralph's shopping bags how big are the
bags they're just they're just a normal
you know a normal grocery bag so the
guitar is sticking right here they just
have the like they just are kind of
using it like oh no put it in that
bag let's go come on DD where's
Dede let's go
I think that's Conan how loud can you
shout
[Laughter]
that's why I'm asking I would like it I
would like it if you stood in the corner
and just shout it as loud oh no oh
really all right it hey take your
head I want to hear those pipes come on
laughs
[Laughter]
also my signature vocal move is
anytime oh Phineas Phineas is being
rushed to the hospital
[Laughter]
you know what I'll tell you something
else uh my signature song move when I'm
singing a song is I always put in and I
did it years ago I was singing a thing
I've done it in front of a lot of like
big deal people yeah I'll be they'll
want me doing it was for some bid or
we're doing a song together and I would
put in
and I would put that in at the end and I
did that in front of Sting and he was
like what the was that why did you
do that that's so good and I'm like I
don't know it's the thing I do at the
end of a song yeah and you know what I'm
happy to come and put that at the end of
any song that you guys right now
definitely have you do that on the next
record yeah
that was the most that was the politest
you the actor I couldn't even look
you in the eye when I said
look at that that's a note that no one's
ever hit before right Sona they
shouldn't yeah nobody wants to
all right listen I don't want to keep
these guys because I think they have a
heart out there's no way we're done what
yeah yeah no way this is you're part of
a huge machine I was told I'd be
murdered if you guys weren't out of here
I don't even I don't actually have a
heart out to you no
retro well I have to be somewhere at six
but that's in like two hours isn't it
actually I have a heart out so